what
how's it going right
my name is paratah and welcome to fry my
plan on your channel shocks me if you're
just quite Megan video anyway today
we're gonna open some more fun mail I
got a lot way too much I need I need my
f for backup
pretty much so let's do it the first one
also verbs you never play amnesia
anymore
what so there's no excuse for [ __ ]
barrel what what did you come
I'm I'm sorry I don't play as much
amnesia anymore I'm gonna try to change
that up this morning it really old
cookies haha I'm not gonna throw these
away I'm gonna he's all like so good
it's a really big one it's very
lightweight does don't know why I'm
talking to max Max's talent is that even
though but what the [ __ ]
ticket Merry Christmas and happy
knitting
thank you betcha we couldn't find any
barrels since then we got you a fat flat
pan and a hat for your flat flat flat
Panda and
I will enjoy but wait
beautiful there's actually two of them
cool oh good a do I lack
Maya next one for you two quick throw Oh
Trish dad father [ __ ]
oh you can't be doing that
yes oh look at this dogs all decided she
cares
this one says brofist on the package you
know it's got to be good if it says
brofist on the package Jeff you slept
dear goodbye I have a few questions do
you like Lady gaga
I [ __ ] love Lady gaga
what's your favorite singer Lady gaga
I like thing we're not a battery so
what's up I'm orange now probably aah oh
my god yeah
mr. Brown photo Anisha I love that it's
awesome look at detail it
penis in it away that's not I love this
Thank You rod it's awesome and and
Slenderman his head is a little I don't
know maybe he's always like this I never
saw him from an angle ha ha ha ha that's
how in Austin and Jeremy dear us know
who all did well got a pump blemish into
this [ __ ]
we've got an awesome cardboard kids look
at that
it's identical I don't have that much
beard though and my beard isn't green
but otherwise and it's awesome
and it stands up on my hat the time has
come for the biggest and the heaviest
package what could this be what the hell
is this wah ha ha so much chocolate
painting closing my eyes nothing my eyes
look at it together I want some of that
Swedish hot meat and we got dark side
Frost
you could you have to send me your oh
damn yo Bravo's [ __ ] I was happy like
I had a right you got around plan - one
oh thank you bros no more and it says
adios [ __ ] battle spread co-chair
spot Sivan hi there today we're sending
this to you from Bulgaria it's pretty
awesome game in the box we want you to
play it of course you do CDs should be
fine
if I had to goodbye I hope this package
is delivered by Christmas sorry about
that I just wanted to say you're awesome
and I love you in your videos and closed
in this package I have a few goodies
fight mm-hmm hot ladies I'd like to say
that you are my hero
on days when I'm feeling down and don't
want to deal with the world I just
turned on your videos after watching for
a couple hours I feel so much better and
get the warm happy feeling you really
save me from myself and I know there are
a few bros who feel the same way
brofist from ellis oh yeah yeah yeah oh
that is really sweet
oh it says brofist in the back join the
bro army it's like with violence
we support violence if you brought no we
don't don't don't punch people only
bully you can punch people with a
breakfast that's really sweet of Alyssa
I appreciate that message someone sent
me a hat that means I have to wear it
right what the hell is this
no way
no why
oh I was it that was fun
thank you I enjoyed that
ah
cabron pewds would like you to join the
bro army subscribe or we will [ __ ]
kill you I love that answer
Thank You rap chants from um communist
no wait um awesome hats gotta sit a bit
further back so you can see my awesome
hat
sorry about that hi first there are a
lot of more packages but I don't think I
have time for more today I just want to
say this makes me so happy to see all
all the stuff and all nice messages that
there's such a love for just me making
videos I don't know it's just this is
really what means something to me it is
what makes me happy the things that I
get from you bros and that's that's what
I've been why I've been doing YouTube
videos and that's why I'm gonna keep
making YouTube videos because if you
wrote and I don't know I said a lot but
that allowed I just totally made my day
she's opening these nails it's been it's
been difficult these last two months I
think because of what happened and I
talked about it in the apology video but
it seems after that that it really made
a lot of difference you know I feel a
lot better about it I feel like it's
only positive right now I feel super
excited like even though we accomplished
so much already like being that whatever
it is top ten subscribed on YouTube even
just accomplishing that I still feel
excited I still feel really pumped for
what's what's next you know what's gonna
what's more in the future
I don't know I hope you both feel the
same I stinky bros a million for all the
support and stay awesome my nostrils
will now say goodbye nostrils shush
I keep telling them not to say nein
anyway and then with the same joke this
last time all right
first Harry comes SACEM my demo activate